I grew up watching Johnny Carson and
loving Johnny Carson I watched him with
my dad and then Dave start to come on
after Johnny and it was when I saw it
for the first time that's what I talked
about in this article that was was just
that it was oh wait a minute this is not
right but in the most beautiful way yes
this is completely wrong and that's what
true ingenious looks like isn't it weird
how Dave eat dressed even more Square
and nerdy than Johnny Carson did and it
took you a second to realize how weird
he was it was almost like he was going
dude I'll dress like the squares but I'm
actually one of you and I'll let them
I'll let them Internet when it's way too
late right you know so you felt like one
of your own yeah I had put on you know
like you almost felt like you were in a
James Bond movie and you and Dave had
beaten up a couple of the guards and put
the jumpsuits on and now he was walking
in and he was gonna this makes no sense
the Death Star all right you had me at
the Death Star although ice quickly
realized that you're basically saying I
think we're the Death Star no it was the
Death Star no weird that we're the
cantina Panther head okay and he's
making run at the Death Star right now
right the huge amazing
explosions gonna happen and in the metal
ceremony so who's Darth Vader who's
Darth Vader you know who drives Vader is
hope Darth Vader are all the people back
in the early 80s that didn't get Dave
they were all of the I'm sure a lot of
people I know that I broke up with a
girlfriend because she's like I don't
know why he just comes on and it's just
uncomfortable right and and and there's
all this quiet I met I had everything
about carrot top
my girlfriend was like I don't he just
smashing stuff and in doing and I
thought you broke up with carrot top
yeah well no that was later yeah yeah I
had no choice I also did how awesome was
it when he would do these things that
you realize that part of the plan was it
for not for it not to work yes so that
then there could be this weird silence
so that it but it was so that feeling of
this is I'm the only thing on NBC right
now and it's dead silent that must have
felt so there is so trust me that feels
great
[Applause]
I was not I was so not ready for this
because I'm still a little freaked out
right by what's by what was gonna happen
tonight why don't I just say that like
he's gonna turn into a vampire yeah yeah
he's big change will happen he'll become
you guys saw the end of Halloween 3
right put your mask on watch why that
was for for people all right
your references are getting narrower as
we get closer to me telling people that
change the I don't think I'm gonna have
to tell them
you're gonna be like they're gonna be
like what the hell baby I'm doing Dave a
favor it's like that scene in the
Andromeda Strain is and it was an early
Michael yeah yeah let's do a commercial
let's do a commercial cuz we have a lot
more to talk about what are you one of
the good people from Creston
all right we'll take a break more with
patton oswalt after this thing around
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please